[Music]
uh
[Applause]
i say either just say either
i say neither can i say neither
either neither neither let's
call the whole thing off
catch up excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
he says hi one is the loneliest number
that you'll ever
do i mean thinking about you
[Music]
you and i are the same
every decision we ever make
[Music]
who do we leave behind
and how do we leave them
waiting in the darkness the rescuer who
never
comes
[Applause]
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
soon come chaos
chaos soon come
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no no you cannot eat mrs chen what
nothing
you